octava jornada de manifestaciones
masivas contra la reforma de pensiones
del presidente Emmanuel macron en
Francia una jornada que aquí en París ha
transcurrido como Ven a mis espaldas sin
violencia en la calma pero también hemos
podido apreciar hoy menos entusiasmo que
en ocasiones anteriores es la octava vez
en que ocurren estas protestas es un
desafío para los sindicatos Sin lugar a
dudas mantener el poder de convocatoria
por ejemplo la semana pasada llegamos a
3,5 millones de personas y es difícil
sostener ese nivel de asistencia también
hay que considerar que es costoso para
los franceses asistir a las
manifestaciones porque si no trabajan
pues evidentemente no cuentan con el
salario de la jornada y también un
elemento esencial estas manifestaciones
no han logrado nada porque el gobierno
de Emanuel macron paso a paso ha ido
venciendo todo el proceso legislativo y
probablemente mañana vea la luz
definitivamente esa reforma de pensiones
del presidente Manuel macron ahora estas
manifestaciones aquí han estado
acompañadas con huelgas en varios
sectores sabemos que los recolectores de
basura llevan ocho días en huelga hay
cerca de siete mil toneladas de
desperdicios en las calles de París que
esperan por ser recogidos pero Incluso
si así sucediera si esto sucediera los
incineradores los lugares donde se quema
la basura permanecen bloqueados o
cerrados el sector de la energía también
se ha sumado a la huelga la mayor
cantidad la mayoría de las refinerías en
Francia permanecen cerradas ha habido
cortes de electricidad en varias
ciudades en algunos edificios
gubernamentales también miembros del
sindicato de la confederación general de
trabajadores pues han ejecutado cortes
del fluido eléctrico en sentido general
una manifestación que pretende presionar
lo que sucede en este momento en la
asamblea nacional